in the wave of Disney's live-action
remakes one just might end up taking the
cake when it comes to critical success
and audience enjoyment yep we're talking
about Moulin a live-action reimagining
of the 1999 smash hit this is everything
you need to know about the upcoming take
on the beloved Disney classic audiences
will have to wait until March 27th 2020
for Mulan's triumphant return to
theaters just over two decades after the
original film's release date in June of
1998 the 2020 release date isn't
surprising as dizzy already packed 2019
with remakes and revivals of animated
properties Dumbo Aladdin The Lion King
Maleficent mistress of evil and lady in
the [ __ ] with so many live-action films
coming out at once it's nice that we'll
get a little bit of a breather before
Mulan takes the stage after all it would
be a shame for the film to lose some
luster simply because audiences are
suffering from live-action remake
fatigue one thing that's a bit
surprising is the fact that while never
on the docket for a 2019 release date
Milan was actually originally slated to
hit the big screen before any of the
aforementioned titles Once Upon a Time
the remake was supposed to be released
on November second 2018 why shift the
date by nearly a year and a half because
it took over a year to find the right
actress to play the lead role once that
was done the film was locked into the
March 27th slot and it looks like it
will be making the rescheduled date
without any issues so how did the
casting process end up pushing the Mulan
remake back by over a year it turns out
that finding the perfect person to play
the lis role wasn't just challenging it
was about as difficult a task as
possible according to The Hollywood
Reporter Disney enlisted a team of
casting directors that visited five
continents where they saw nearly 1,000
different candidates audition for the
role talk about doing your homework it
makes sense though as you don't meet a
girl like this every dynasty the casting
team wasn't just looking for actresses
who had passable martial arts skills and
could speak English fluently
they also made a top-priority out of
finding someone who was ethnically
Chinese as well after spending such a
gargantuan amount of time and effort the
team finally chose the popular Chinese
American actress Liu Yifei
the choice was a near-perfect one lui
is talented and has already proven her
acting chops along with a string of
other projects the actor has starred in
the Forbidden Kingdom and Outkast both
of which saw her holding her own
alongside well-established actors like
Jackie Chan Nicolas Cage and Jet Li Oh
embryonic jostle having worked alongside
him on 2008 The Forbidden Kingdom Luo Yi
Fei is reteaming with Jet Li for Mulan
the martial arts master has been tapped
to play the venerable Emperor of China
this is exciting news even if it's a
fairly reserved role all things
considered here's hoping they can sneak
him into a fight sequence alongside the
titular character in addition to Lee the
film has cast Milan's slapstick trio of
fellow warriors yowling and chien-po
Ling will be played by Jimmy Wong Oh by
dois moi and Chen Tang will be taking up
the role of Yao the so called
king of the rock one significant face
missing from the action though li Shang
the hunky commander has failed to show
up on any casting reports so far instead
it looks like the production team has
opted to split Shang's prominent
character into two separate
personalities Donnie Yen has been cast
as the character commander Tong who
appears to be taking on the role of
Milan's military commander separate from
that relationship we have Chen hung we
played by yoson an it appears that Chen
hungry will be a fellow recruit in
tongues unit who bonds with Mulan before
the two form a romantic relationship
of course even the best past isn't going
to get very far without a good group of
people working behind the scenes as well
fortunately the story of China's warrior
heroine appears to be in good hands
starting at the top Disney has tapped
Niki Caro to helm the project the Kiwi
director has already drawn attention
thanks to her work on films like North
Country the zookeepers wife and
McFarland USA she first established
herself in 2002 with Whale Rider a maori
film with feminist themes of family
destiny and generational divides some
obvious parallels with Mulan for all of
her past accomplishments though a
blockbuster like Mulan could launch
Cairo to new heights in fact the simple
act of taking the job made her the
fourth woman to ever solo direct a film
with a 100 million dollar plus budget
if she manages to knock the project out
of the park then the sky's the limit
along with Cairo a team of four writers
has been brought on to adapt the story
to a live-action format they include
Rick Jaffa Amanda Silver Elizabeth
Martin and Lauren hi Nick Jaffa and
silver are of particular interest as
they have worked together on both
Jurassic world and the recent Planet of
the Apes films this gives them plenty of
experience in bringing classic stories
into the modern era which is encouraging
to say the least before we get too far
into the possible direction that the
live-action remake could take let's take
a quick trip down memory lane and
revisit how Disney z' 1998 animated
version of Mulan played out the film
takes place in ancient China during the
Han Dynasty in response to a hun
invasion the Emperor orders a full
mobilization including one man from
every family this prompts Mulan to buff
tradition and go in her aged father
stage disguised as a young man she is
soon joined by the disgraced Family
Guardian a tiny dragon named Mu Shu and
the two managed to convince everyone
that she can bring the goods after
training with the other recruits mulan's
unit sets out to reinforce the Imperial
Army only to find that they've already
been annihilated by the deadly Huns
Mulan heroically saves her brothers and
arms and you know the whole of China by
causing an avalanche to sweep away the
enemy during an ambush in the process
though she is revealed to be a woman and
is cast out of the army finding that
some of the Huns including their leader
Shan you have survived the Avalanche
Mulan fearlessly follows the soldiers to
the imperial city where she alerts
everyone to the approach of the Huns and
helps foil their attempt to kill the
Emperor ultimately Mulan is recognized
for her heroic deeds and returns home to
celebrations and a visit from her
commander Shang whom she invites to stay
forever oh we mean for dinner would you
like to stay for dinner would you like
to stay forever dinner would be great
while the live-action remake will
obviously be leaning heavily on the 90s
animated classic for the bulk of its
inspiration there's also the original
Chinese legend itself which the writers
can draw from
and based on the gritty realism depicted
in the trailer so far it looks like
they're doing just that of course old
stories like these almost always have a
ton of different versions over the
centuries naturally this means the exact
details of the legend have varied over
the years that said Milan's traditional
story takes place in ancient China
during either the fourth or fifth
century there are many distinctly
similar factors that modern audiences
will recognize in the tale as well for
instance the story always starts with a
horde of barbarians invading China this
leads to Milan volunteering to enlist as
her aged father's son in order to save
him from having to go to war where he'll
meet almost certain death
she takes her family's heirloom weapons
joins up with the army and finds success
as a soldier she even falls in love with
an officer and is offered a reward from
the Emperor at which point she simply
asks for a horse to ride home for all of
the similarities across versions of the
story there are also many things that
are completely different
for example while the animated feature
manages to neatly fit everything into
what feels like a few weeks or possibly
months Milan actually fought in the
ranks as a warrior for a decade we're
talking about a legitimate army career
here not only that but she was
eventually promoted to general status at
one point some stories explain that she
goes into battle dressed as a woman with
the specific intention of inspiring her
men by revealing her true identity it
works and her soldiers gain an even
greater respect for her while Milan does
eventually draw the attention of the
Emperor it's not quite as epic as the
climactic finale of the 90s movie rather
the emperor simply finds out that his
bravest soldier is a woman and impressed
offers her a reward she asks for a horse
and rides home only to find that her
father has died during her long absence
at least in some versions of the story
this tragic ending gets even worse in
some accounts as she is forced to become
the wife or concubine of an emperor in
the end refusing to accept this fate
China's greatest heroine ultimately
takes her own life while he didn't have
a ton of line shan-yu was a pretty
important character in the original
animated film and it wasn't until moolah
literally lit the man up over the
Imperial City that everyone could
breathe a collective sigh of relief
despite his importance though it appears
that the writers have actually decided
to act the big bad from the remake
instead the production team is cashing
in on a little creative liberty and
going in a different if still quite
intimidating direction the film has
brought in Gong Lee known for her role
in Memoirs of a Geisha to play the
powerful witch Xian Lang the official
trailer also sets up another villain the
warlord bori khan but it appears he will
be little more than a front man for
Lang's nefarious plans this shift from
brute force to the supernatural is a
curious one and it'll be interesting to
see how it plays out on the big screen a
trailer also makes a deliberate attempt
to compare Mulan to a Phoenix which
traditionally sits at the right hand of
the Emperor and is his guardian and his
protector while also showing the witch
literally turning into a bird of prey
indicating a foul showdown of some sort
or another is afoot on top of that one
of the trailers even showcases a duel
between the two female warriors of
course what would a Mulan remake be
without the guardian of lost souls the
eddie murphy voiced moo shu is one of
the most fondly remembered elements of
the original animated classic you demand
moo shu superfans should be careful
before they get their hopes too high
when it comes to the remake though while
the fan blogged is insider did report
that a source had claimed the little guy
would be in the film very little
information has come out about what his
actual role would be will we see the
powerful the pleasurable the
indestructible moo shu or will we see a
live-action alternative that is more
subdued and subtle maybe we won't get an
actual character at all but merely a
quick glimpse of a small dragon statue
or some other easter egg so far no one
is reported to have been cast in the
role which doesn't bode well for a
direct adaptation from the 90s original
however fans can take comfort in the
fact that the cast list does contain an
entry for a character named cricket
which hints that perhaps Mushu sidekick
crickey will somehow be represented the
official trailer seems to heavily imply
that the story will be steering into the
Mulan the Phoenix angle pretty hard
it even cuts to a shot of a live Phoenix
while Milan's father is asking the
ancestors to protect her perhaps instead
of seeing no protector will simply be
seeing Mushu swapped out for a more
appropriately epic Phoenix Guardian
check out one of our newest videos right
here plus even more Luper videos about
your favorite style for coming soon
subscribe to our YouTube channel and hit
the bells so you don't miss a single one
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]